I'm talking everybody needs to hear this
is crush' 2008 it I was right it's real
like people are still not doing it you
got your perspective hey guys it's
Garrity Vaynerchuk super excited about
being back on the podcast really really
just hopeful everybody's doing super
well and let's just really get right at
this conversation with Sam I'm gonna let
him introduce himself and then I will
take it away Sam won't you tell the
Vayner nation who you are what you're
about and then we'll go into it yeah I'm
Sam par I own this company called the
hustle so we started out with
conferences and things like that and I
could talk about that but yeah we had
this conference called hustle con after
I sold one company I saw this thing
called hustle con it's basically like a
TED talk for entrepreneurs but I made it
popular by creating an email newsletter
and then I was like this email
newsletter thing's awesome so kind of
parlayed it into the hustle and so now
we're a daily email with about one and a
half million daily readers and
bootstrapped a media company each
morning we give like I said about a
million to have people all the business
news and information they need to know
and then we've parlayed that into a
bunch of other things like a paid
subscription called trends podcast and a
bunch of other things like that so how
about as a kid like were you
entrepreneurial yeah so I grew up in
Missouri and then I went to college in
Tennessee and when I was in Tennessee I
own a chain of hotdog stands called
Southern Sam's weiners as big as a
baby's arm man and like how old were you
I started when I was like 20 but before
that I was selling stuff on eBay but
like that was my first legal business I
got business license and paid taxes and
things like that
have you seen a TV show called American
Pickers yes so Mike the main guy the
skinny guy I met him on the street cuz I
was a big fan and I asked him to work at
his company at his store he was opening
up a store where they sell like all the
old [ __ ] and I worked there and it was
great but there was always a line of
like a thousand people and I was like
I'm gonna go open up a hot dog stand
sell hot dogs these people and that's
what happened
because the show was so famous Tapia
when I worked there in 2011 or no sorry
2008 or 9 or something like that we were
number two on cable behind Pawn Stars
and all these people from around the
world would come and get in this line
where was that it was in Nashville and
that but is he like he's into old stuff
right so he got this old building that
was away from everything and there's no
restaurants and I was like huh
these cats I'm from the south so I can
say this but they're kind of rednecks
who would come and wait in line and I
was like these [ __ ] what's up hot
dogs at water that's all they what and I
opened up this hotdog stand and that was
like my first hustle yeah first business
made money and I'd pay taxes and got
licenses and how did that go how long
did you do it for a few years I mean you
would make a grand a day on a good day
yeah it was awesome and then I started a
website that made a little bit of money
but I was like oh the Internet's the way
to go and so I left school and moved up
to Silicon Valley in San Francisco and
originally had job offers that air B&B
but at the time was called air
bed-and-breakfast but I was like you
know screwed this let's try to start
something so I started a roommate
matching app that had a small exit and
then kind of parlayed that into the
hustle and what I'm doing now and what
was that company called and who did sell
- it was called bunk originally bunk SF
it was so what we would do is it was
kind of funny we would cold email all
these landlords and apartments of who
had two three four five bedroom
apartments and then we would host
parties so people who had similar once
and needs for living situation could all
meet one another and we would help them
move into these buildings and we would
take a small cut of like a placement fee
and so it was a small exit like hundreds
of thousands of dollars to apartment
list so apartment lists calm and did you
have to work in that company or now yeah
and I quit on the first day was like
that last day how was that how would you
know as somebody who now it sounds like
your whole career has been for yourself
how was that year working so it was good
like I still don't know [ __ ] like I had
to read books on like how to run a
meeting so I felt like I'm going to San
Francisco from Tennessee I and I'm
gripping Missouri I always felt really
uncomfortable and out of place there but
I love it now I didn't know anything
like I would say things that were
inappropriate I would wear stuff I
wasn't supposed to wear I just felt
horrible so it was good to see like what
an actual
businesses run like but I was also young
I was 22 and I was partying and I didn't
take it as seriously as I should have
and I regret that big time but it was
great to see what was the biggest tip
what would you argue the one or two or
three biggest takeaways were from that
year even though you're sorry up like
okay so you guys have a great set up
here okay um you started in like a small
room I imagine that's a shitty office
that's right and so just seeing like
wait I could take all these little silly
things like a hotdog stand or whatever
and like properly build it out with nice
offices after you get revenue and like
like I need you in order to get huge and
as bigs my efficiency where you really
need to properly approach things and be
able to like have a proper levels as
opposed to have you started the
challenge proper so like for example
what was funny running through my mind
in when you just said you know I read
books on how to run a meeting properly I
was like laughing in my head because I
was like [ __ ] man I probably hate that
book right because like to me like
meetings and like how the world those
proper things you're referring to see
meetings and how I personally see
meetings there's a huge Delta and I'm
Kal do you know I just I'm 30 I'm
curious you know uh someone who also
came from out of bounds and never
understood proper I always wonder I'm
always challenging myself of like what
was I naturally gifted in in an
entrepreneurial and human way what has
evolved over these 22 years of operating
and what have I taken on that is
horseshit because it's osmosis yeah I
know what I feel you but in my here in
my mind it's like this okay when you
play an instrument when you learn the
guitar you don't it's most people don't
play songs of their own songs right away
they kind of copy other people and feel
the texture and they go oh I see some
kind of like the the stuff that I like I
see recurring patterns yep this is
interesting I can I can disregard this
other stuff so what I do is I usually
read books
oh I'll read like I'll read your guyses
glass doors okay
other companies glass doors alright what
do people say well yeah like what's the
baseline for like what is interesting
and I can you can hit cherry-pick but
like you don't know like anything you
have it's easier to have like a model
and then you can know what to do
yeah but I would argue that your analogy
for the way you went about it unless I'm
missing something is actually not flawed
but not exactly the same analogy because
it sounds like based on your hot dog
business what you're telling me is you
didn't play other people's music you
picked it up started playing something
and within that micro area it worked
yeah I would also I would also argue
that you know it's really interesting
where the source of information comes
from right so there's a lot of business
books being written by people who've
never run a business
biographies fair enough Glassdoor is
just anonymous reviews usually goes very
dirty day that one foreign or one other
end that's what I mean I mean you're at
this young age where you've had these
levels of successes you know I have such
empathy for where you're coming from
because I'm sure I had a lot of those
same feelings of like I'm from out of
bounds I don't go to business school and
things of that nature and I remember
ironically it's an interesting for you
to bring that up
I also remember kind of hitting the
Silicon Valley scene and like every
single person went to Stanford and
Harvard it's uncomfortable and I was
like thank God for me very different for
you that I already had such a real
significant win that I was able to kind
of use that but I have so much empathy
for what must have been going through
your mind in that scenario on the flip
side you're catching me at a very funny
time where I would not what are we 20
for these eight weeks are probably the
favorite eight weeks of being an
operator in a long time because I
decided going into this year that I was
gonna go more me because I've really let
the company do its thing I'm running the
company but I've let the osmosis of like
classic executives have a lot of say
over the last half decade and I would
argue that the last eight weeks have
been some of those productive weeks at
vaynermedia's history and definitely my
favorite time in the last 40 years
because I'm going back a little bit to
hot dog with the baby arm [ __ ] yeah I I
don't disagree we agree I think that but
it's still important it was important
for me to understand because you needed
that context yeah I get it I get it like
probably like all right I'm just gonna
pick take this thousand dollars of cash
I'm gonna put that [ __ ] right in my
pocket right like I'm gonna incriminate
myself but you don't to be you're gonna
spend it on some dumb [ __ ] well I didn't
know
oh you got it keep going huh you know I
just did do things too right didn't do
proper accounting things I got it now
that we have an eight-figure you know we
make seven figures a month is it good I
think it could be a very large company
just learning how to do [ __ ] properly
now not everything needs to be proper no
I'll take the outside world but like
there are some things for like all right
I got to make sure I do things the right
way 100% you know when things go from
just have you brought in people like
Adam is our president which who I knew
from high school he kind of he's the
president runs a lot of the day-to-day
stuff he's a straight man yeah yeah and
so I'm able to like I'm able to kind of
be my wild self and then well we don't
always meet in the middle sometimes I I
will still go the wild route but like
there I have some proper procedures dude
for a while I was doing the accounting
and not good a night it was like I
thought cash flow and revenue were the
same thing I bet guys we got to get
these people put that money in our bank
that's not revenue I'm not paying your
quota on that and I get it and you learn
all that right stuff you know how that
the right way to do it that's what I'm
referring to
I totally understand you know how it is
like not coming from this area it's
really uncomfortable at first but it's
actually a advantage in the end I think
a hundred thousand percent I used to
have this book club called the anti MBA
because when I moved to San Francisco so
jealous of all these Stanford people so
I would create this book club and we'd
meet once a week and then we'd get
experts to come in and lead the
discussion and I was like look we just
did the same thing as Stanford of course
but yeah it's really uncomfortable I
think you know how it is what are you
thinking about going forward like
where's your mindset um on like the next
half decade decade next year like what's
as an operator as a founder as an
entrepreneur what's exciting you right
now our business is doing well I wanna I
mean I don't necessarily care about
money but I'm a runner an older I rank
in college and so I love having goals I
want to hit 100 million in revenue by
2025 and I'm really excited I think
there's a lot of media brands out there
who operate horribly and aren't doing
the right things I think we can build a
massive B to be publicly explained to me
on that like what are your some hot what
are your hot takes on the I think the
New York medias being seen is horrible
because I think that they look at Google
Analytics more than actually talk
to users and talk to customers and
figure out like what people want and
they create [ __ ] they love they don't
treat them like customers it's just
google analytics it's like oh we just
change this headline to this that's
gonna do it's like well what's that what
does that really mean and what you're
seeing now is that's actually impacting
people in the long run this is why
Barnstable sports sold for what their
stock just one of my 50% their sale
price was effectively now like 650
million dollars right and Dave doesn't
know [ __ ] I bet at first about analytics
I was an entrepreneur he just made stuff
that people loved whereas a lot of the
big companies what are now big they
don't do that as much and I think that
that's gonna humor them and it will help
us so non consumer centric quant centric
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which like you
need you can have a little bit of that
we're not they're gonna cut like vice
what are they where do they value that
like two or three billion dollars yeah I
mean I think we need to talk about vice
you have to talk about the narrative I
mean one of the variables in this whole
game is you know I don't know the story
so I can't speak to it but my perception
from the outside is some of the founders
and investors adviced it extremely well
because that's all Smith sitting front
row that Tyson Fury fight yeah I mean
you know that becomes that's a very big
part of vc-backed businesses over the
last half decade that will be the legacy
of this 10-year window which is what was
the Delta between building long-term
businesses you know how much leverage
did founders have to beat able to take
money off the table at Ceres be in
Series C levels was that what they were
actually going for you know I you know
Shane had an you know again just not
knowing a lot about vice but one thing I
definitely knew because I was in the
circles of medium brands Shane had a
remarkable ability to sell so good you
know big brands big you know big budgets
so you know there's so many I'm with you
like something like here's the
difference they say let's say vice post
something like on their social Channel
it says our top reporter is gonna be
here tomorrow show up now let's say Gary
post I'm gonna be here tomorrow show up
who's who's gonna have the most poll of
course right yeah they have a billion
dollars or eight hundred million dollars
in funding or something like that yep
that's me is did you
are you self-funded for this business we
took a little bit of angel money so I
had self-funded it we made I made my the
first couple conferences I made five
hundred grand in profit and I piled all
that money into this then we took small
checks from Tim Ferriss the founders of
nerd wallet the founders of bleacher
report people like that like various
people that you thought could bring down
yeah because I was like email more money
bullet out ask them questions and
they're like can I invest I'm like wait
you're gonna give me money and I can
just text you questions whenever I want
so we did a little bit of that smart no
venture capital what's the UH what's the
best piece of advice you've gotten from
either smart money or outside people or
you consumed somewhere in the last let's
call the last year what's with some
personal advice please Joe speiser who
started little things calm which
eventually went out but he's very
successful um he was like I'm gonna
write you this cheque but just know I
just bought a big house in the Hamptons
it's not gonna make you happy
yeah so like you give me that right he
gave us the money yeah
what are some other good advice Tim
Ferriss has been really helpful I mean
he's like anal retentive about his brand
and about everything like that yeah and
I think there's a little middle ground
there but like just seeing like how
strict he is with his brand and it
totally works for him and it has made
him so him it's so good and I really
respect that where are you at this point
in your life between money legacy the
process if I said if I said 30-year old
you right now between generally in your
stomach in your heart in your gut about
how much you're driven by and how much
you like the net win is around dollars
is around being able to do your process
and around legacy
how are you currently broken down
between a hundred percent of those well
I don't have children yet so maybe
things will change but I have enough
that I don't have to worry for maybe it
forever I find my I thought I was really
money motivated but we get all these
like opportunities when you get to a
little bit of a level like we'll pay you
10 grand to come here and do this or
whatever and I just denied and I found
myself not wanting to do that because I
don't I'm like huh that sounds so boring
to me I don't want to do that so I guess
I answered the question of where I am a
little bit
I would I mean like one time we had a
client do something that we thought it
was an [ __ ] thing and we fired them
and we lost a quarter of a million
dollars and I slept like a baby so I
don't think I'm as money moded money
motivated as I thought do you think that
because you checked some sort of box for
yourself along the way versus no and I
really must say I think I had [ __ ] you
money when I had 10 grand yeah I get
that I don't stay yeah I do know that
like and then once I was like wait a
minute I still don't think I've ever
been more rich than when I was doing
baseball card shows at 13
because 3000 $4000 when you're 13 and
you came from nothing set I thought I
had like a trail again
I remember one day I sold hotdogs and I
had a grip of cash it was like a great
grip yeah it was just a grip it was like
we call it I call it a grip let me get
that grip and it was it was because I
had like a jar here tonight and I had
like a grand and five dollar bills and I
was like this is for me money this is it
I was I was like like we called it hood
rich and where did you grow up again in
st. Louis Missouri but then I lived in
Nashville Tennessee but I grew up with a
lot of like poor people and you know
that's why I talk like this but I
thought you'd like it did you think
about was you happy
so in Nashville I lived across the
street from the projects and we would
hang out all the time I was old were you
then 19 to 21
hey you're 21 and I would just hang out
there with my buddy right out and we
would just chill and just sit on it was
the most it was I was my happiest when I
had nothing which is weird right no I
think it's I think it's not weird at all
but uh what you guys talk about just
shoot like guy talk girls sports just
random [ __ ] or would you talk about
dreams business yeah I mean he this dude
had served 25 years in prison and he
would talk about that but just stupid
stuff but it was just it's really fun I
think that when you come from not a lot
which you know I had a good family and
everything but when you start from when
you're trying to start on your own from
scratch do you have siblings yeah yeah
I have siblings all the brother and
older sister you were the youngest
mm-hmm yeah I think when you start from
not a lot okay it's actually a huge
advantage and you could be a lot happier
that way I think if I think if you're
born into a wealthy family the
likelihood of like depression might
actually be higher I think so
you know what I mean based on our
societal norms right now so much of my
passion about like what I talk about and
the content I put out is to create
empathy for it's very hard I you know I
get it I grew up in it it's very hard
for somebody that doesn't have much to
have empathy for somebody who's driving
a BMW and has a Rolex but you know based
on all my readings all my DM so I get at
this point in my life I have some
wondrous of thousands of interactions
per month year or whatever it is it's
just a lot of interactions I see far
more sadness and people that had too
much then people had too little
I see Envy in people that don't have as
much I see thriving people that don't
have as much I see
resentment and people that don't have as
much I see deep lostness and people that
have too much you know like there's just
when people didn't have as much they
there is an inherent I'm gonna pull
myself out of this whether it's illegal
legal there's a drive it's really hard
to be hungry when you started fed it
just is not and I agree and I have I
have wealthy kids and I think about it
constantly so let me ask you a question
I bet a lot of people wonder or maybe a
fair bit so you started this from
nothing yep
I started my business from nothing I saw
early on even once we got to like 25 30
employees once it got to like 10 million
in revenue I was like I don't want to
operate or I don't want to like be the
guy of this business I want to just go
start from the bottom again and start
stuff within the company that's what I
prefer yep you seem like you would
prefer that but you see like you're
still like the guy in charge I do both
the reason I have team Gary is it is my
little pirate ship how many people work
their team Gary yeah
thirty or so it feels right so I have my
little I garyvee my team Gary my case
was collaboration my empathy wine
residue k-swiss know your team Gary know
it is part of so how do you allocate
budget to that we use it as we allocate
it because I have full control and we
look at it as a as two things one the
testing ground for hypotheses that
become the scalable strategies and
talent grooming
and top of the funnel business awareness
we don't have to do our of peace cuz I'm
Gary B Gary V happened because of Team
Gary so it instead of most companies
that I compete with at the level that we
compete at who have enormous allocations
to new business teams and spend tons of
money on RFPs we do none of that
and it amortizes out into the content
engine which becomes far more strategic
than spending $50,000 on a sizzle reel
to try to get McDonald's to hire you so
just walk in and say hi Russ dick do you
like running an 800 person company yes
I'm an opera you know one thing with me
that is interesting and I would argue
that it is potentially a weakness
because I have so much magic back to you
know kind of where you're going with
this
ironically I also had a ton of
operational capability I've basically
been the CEO oh the operating decision
maker for my companies my whole life
I mean AJ played that role but he was by
nature having an 11-year younger brother
he was so capable so it was great but I
also there was a lot of operational
conversations we had together and so I
am capable to operate and I often debate
with myself [ __ ] you know even though I
love it I love it ultimately I operate
because I actually like operating
because I have a real interesting
distinction between the sizzle and the
steak that both sit within me that is me
who's your number 2 number 3 number 4
who's like they're so at Vayner really
might at Vayner medium my number 2 is
really I mean it's really an interesting
mix vfo yes and no right because I'm not
CFO driven you know and listening to
your stories I get where you're coming
from
like and I have a lot of that too like
I'm far better at literally doing
something nobody else can do then
balancing checkbooks like it's just
boring ass buck to me back to cash flow
and yada I went through all those same
things I'm like [ __ ] this you know like
but what I will tell you is my number
two is a collective I would argue
between claude claude i always think of
claude as my number two because she's
the cheap hard officer which is really
HR which i really believe is the punch
line no matter how it rates like the
hiring roadmap yeah but
she's also gray she's not it she even
has a number two in Generosa like she
herself is kind of like more you and me
then she is a straight person but I
think that's exactly right for HR HR is
a function of humanity same way you
cynically properly by the way cynically
look at all the Google Analytics media
companies that's how I think about HR I
don't give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] hiring
structure I care about humanity
I don't care about [ __ ] all this
stuff we're supposed to do for the
states that were in it though we have to
do that so we don't get sued and become
liable but what I care about is Clawd
knowing what [ __ ] is on I sit down
with Seth he I'm looking right at him
right now I had four I had something
canceled I see Seth on the [ __ ] floor
and I literally success coming to my
office and we have a ten minute talk
about Seth's life this is real life this
happened a week ago right Seth like
that's what I'm about right and I don't
want to speak for Seth it's probably
hard for me to ask you within being in
the room but I have a funny feeling
Seth's relationship with vaynermedia is
better today than it was a week and a
half ago because we got to have that
talk clarity and roadmap that's how you
build a big your your game is not gonna
be like at real scale when I hear the
level of ambition of a hundred million
by 2025 one I personally get scared
about that I like people who first of
all you know yourself I'm not a runner
thus it makes sense to me but I'm always
inherently always nervous because I'm
like don't put that extra pressure on
you you know like but to your point you
know how to motivate yourself you do you
number two my belief is no matter how
remarkable the two of you are I'm kind
of like this the sizzle and the steak
that the most important variable to get
to a Hondo is HR okay so you have your
HR person report which both of you might
be remarkable at I just don't know
understood
make sense so you have hunting farming
yeah so you have Claude Claude then mark
yard kid our general counsel far out
seeds that title he's far more of a CEO
oh he's been here from basically day one
he was my personal lawyer when I
invested in Twitter and Facebook and
he's like this kid must be right and I
recruited him and we had a general
counsel long before I thought it was
appropriate but I just knew he was right
I was like [ __ ] it I'll get there
eventually and good because he's been a
coincidence it's a year or whatever the
[ __ ] you call those things and a and a
general counsel and and is evolving more
and more
- CIO life Marcus Cruz a stick who's my
my brother's best friend since first
grade started here should have never
worked at Vayner but the economy
collapsed it was a super bright kid and
I had like nothing but finance offers
but like he's an EQ kid it turns out and
was smart enough to come here and just
intern and he's my chief of staff
he's a quote-unquote number two I would
argue that and an Allen would agree with
me Allen probably falls more into a
number three as a CFO I'm just basically
I'm on the hyperbole not hyperbole I'm
in the real life of pay the bills invest
pay the bills invest it's all in
perpetuity so I'm not looking to extract
too many dollars out of the business at
this point in my life because I can
afford to and so I want to build a
machine that um that you know my admin
team Alex Lew max my admin team is a
real factor in my life back to the joke
we made before here like everybody's
listening I sat down was like all right
excited be on your podcast he looked at
me as like [ __ ] on mine you were
so my go [ __ ] like that's how I am you
know I'm sure I don't need you to I but
it was a great insight for you of like
how high level I'm really playing it cuz
it really ultimately doesn't matter like
the context I needed for here as you can
see in the way I mean I know enough I
know enough from afar I know enough of
like right I know how to bring the most
value to you into my audience so like I
like I don't spend time on things that I
don't need to spend time on so we have
we have this thing we launch trends it's
pretty cool where we where we do if we
basically uncover interesting
opportunities so it makes a ton of sense
yeah so it's a pay basically it's like
I've seen them I've seen the model my
whole life it's a paid newsletter with a
group and commuting we're gonna scale up
like political Pro whatever and the
point with trends right now is we're
uncovering cool opportunities so we'll
do like a case study on a cool company
like right now I'm writing one just in
the hotel industry I think there's a lot
of opportunities in hotels and what kind
of breakdown the financials I love that
or will we have technology across the
web and find things that are
fast-growing like for example people are
searching for ways to sleep better more
than they're searching for meditation
stuff I'm aware and so be just will
uncover that and talk about what it
means it's cool exploding that
opportunity and one of the things that
we talked about on that and on our
podcast is just like the real like the
eken
except different things of different
businesses and how they operate how many
employees do you guys have
we have almost 900 ok [ __ ] so what I'm
curious about and I think a lot of
people might be is when so we took I
made about $4,000 five hundred thousand
dollars in profits from the conference
that's what I used to fund our
advertising business now those made a
lot of profits which one or five fund
this thing and that thing and so that's
our funding route how were you guys able
to scale to 800 people did you have did
you get a one line of credit no we got a
free conference room the size of this so
that was our first overhead me and AJ
didn't take any salary
AJ needed AJ saved money from eBay in
high school in college I had I was an
interesting spot I didn't own Wine
Library the part of my narrative a lot
of people don't realize is in family
businesses you don't like almost every
employee made as much if not more than
me so I was you know my in my 20s I was
making forty to fifty seven 63 so the
last couple years I got up to a little
around a hundred but I lived in New York
and right before Vayner started I took
all my liquid and invested in Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr can you reveal how
much ya like to how much did I put in
like to 2047 and 71 so somewhere in the
ballpark of I had a in my whole life
I've been able to save about 400
thousand bucks because I paid like eight
nine hundred dollars in rent and I
worked 18 hours a day and what did you
put all 400 to those all of it it was
crazy but if you think about how big of
a win it it's kind of like sports cards
right now so like this sports card thing
is really funny like we just covered
those auctions on trends actually I love
the Heritage Auctions yes growing like
crazy crazy and if like LeBron rookies
have gone up from a thousand like like
it's really funny I think a lot of
people think I'm talking about sports
cards right now because I know my
narrative that I grew up with them but I
also try to remind my closest friends
who are like calling me now and be like
yo especially as they see the videos of
like me and April saying bye LeBron at a
thousand now it's 45 hundred you know by
Gianna's for 180 now it's 1500 by Luca
for 35 now it's 280 like now I've got
like the receipts and it's happened
within
six months and everyone's like wait a
minute is there something actually
coming here and I told my friends are
like look I've been passion about sports
cards since I was 11 I also haven't said
a word about them for 20 years so it's
really happening the reason I bring that
up is this is one of the first things
I've seen that is so unbelievably
obvious to me that I did the same thing
that I did with investing which is if
it's a hundred percent not 99 if it's 99
I'm an immigrant and I'm gonna hold 50%
back but if it's a hundred and you two
excuse me Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
were a hundred percent to me and that'd
be keep that was right so that crushed
it we sold an eighty four thousand
dollar campaign to a guy that I went to
a basketball game with who was a Wine
Library customer who invited me because
it was a huge collector and literally in
the second quarter of this boring Mets
game in the old stadium in Jersey he
goes so what are you up to him was like
actually cuz I felt calm I hadn't told
anybody I was like actually my brother's
about to graduate in two months and I
kind of start a business with him and
I'm probably gonna spend you know I'm
gonna you know what I said I know what I
said to him like I'm 150% don't worry
I'm gonna be a hundred percent on Wine
Library because it's my big customer but
I'm gonna put a lot of effort into
building this company with my brother
and he said and turns out that he was in
marketing and he had this big campaign
for Gillette starting around when before
AJ graduated our first campaign was
before AJ graduated it was like this
[ __ ] influencer Twitter campaign in
Vegas for Gillette's raisers and they
paid us eighty four thousand dollars
which i thought was like a trillion
especially compared to what we did I
tried to get them to do like 94 smart
things like now just take some photos
nonetheless that eighty four thousand is
the funding that's pretty crazy to me
because with our business I mean we
haven't taken a lot of funding but I
still am like how close do we want to
run it run our margins and then but you
have to like put money up for rent right
so in San Francisco and well in here you
got to put you know your deposit in well
it's funny right like you know we have a
lot of jobs we're putting out there at
like you know 40 and 50 and people are
like how can you live in New York they
like yell at me and I'm like by not
living in Manhattan by not buying $7
Starbucks by not taking uber and
trait like you could do anything like
you know to your point you just thought
you know you were in a little bit
different place you were in that world
you made a couple hundred you made some
money on that exit you were also in the
cocoon of fun right you were in San
Francisco cocoon yeah well now most of
our people in Austin exactly like you
know you from mentality of st. Louis and
Nashville and you know you as the person
that was living in a cocoon of San
Francisco like there's you can do
anything if you're willing to not be
entitled if you're willing to be
practical this is this is where
Americans get caught with immigrants all
the time how could how can this happen
very easy like you live humbly as [ __ ]
you save money and you then deploy that
money it's not super complicated you did
it I did it my dad definitely did it and
like a billion [ __ ] people have done
it in America over the last hundred
years it's that people are impatient and
insecure and so the yeah I mean that's
how we did it and like oh were you
running we didn't pay rent for the first
two and a half years of the company what
you guys run in you till your bank you
guys running on a slim bank balance even
for a couple years yes and no we didn't
pay rent again because I bartered I
asked like you know I already had a
little street cred because of my wine
business I was able to use me a little
bit so that's true I just think that
when you have like 300 employees it's
like [ __ ] like yeah but I by that point
we had a you know a 300 employees we
were doing you know 87 million dollars
in revenue like you know at that point
you're balancing it but yeah I mean it's
also not you know what it comes down to
an I'm curious how you think about this
and I hope you've been able to hold on
to this because they'll make you
unstoppable I'm also super like I'm
actually secretly excited about a
headline in the New York Times that says
vaynermedia lays off half as his staff
after the recession because if I made
the wrong decisions of same which won't
happen but if I did I'd still be okay
with it here's why I deserve it I made
the mistake I liked being accountable
I'm really into accountability I really
think it needs to get like super cool
Alex do me a favor text Andy Kane right
now and tell him I want it accountable
as [ __ ] hoodie made him medial I want to
wear it see if we can get it to me this
afternoon accountable as [ __ ] in the
same way I apologize I just want to say
this like in the same way that I think
kindness and empathy and page
needed to be a bigger part of the
formula of entrepreneurship which is why
I've talked about a lot more
I think accountability like I just wish
that every entrepreneur back to your
point razor thin margins what does that
mean you can get caught if you're okay
with getting caught and paying the
ramifications you win if you're not as
you know and I've been listening to you
on this interview people creating exits
in mediaand creating exits that look
like it's an exit you know wasn't next
they sold their assets for a penny on
the dollar but they wanted they didn't
have the guts to say we shut down so
they sold early right people are not
willing to be uncomfortable I'm willing
to put my own cash back into vaynermedia
if I [ __ ] up I'm willing to have to
let go ten percent of worst employees at
Boehner if nine of our clients fire us
like [ __ ] changes things I just do that
shows all time
where I'm like if this business goes out
of business tomorrow I'll be fun I'm
gonna be I'll be fine you know why cuz
you will be fine right and so that's
right and I do that exercise all the
time because it's so good first start
about this o my personality settle for
this but then it now it's like if we go
away tomorrow I'll be just as happy I
would and then kind of like when you
protect your downside that mean you have
no downside then and it's only upside
and so that's kind of how we discuss it
I've said it a billion times they'll say
it again I want to lose everything
have everybody [ __ ] on me say that I was
a farce the whole time see how everybody
else was better than me I was the joke
see make fun of all the people that
bought into me all that and then just
rise back up and [ __ ] tell everybody
go [ __ ] themselves like I'm into that
[ __ ] yeah I mean it's really helpful
because it's free it's it's unbelievably
freeing it's very freeing what else is
exciting for you to talk about what else
is on your mind what else do you think
will bring value to people listening
what's been what's been actually let me
ask you this way what's been something
that you feel your readers which I'm
sure overlap very heavily with this
audience I'm sure plenty of them read
already have been really hot on what's
but like what do you guys put out in
like [ __ ] we knew it and yeah they
really are hot on it well I want to talk
specific business things so that we're
going over so like different ideas and
concepts and I mean I'm I'm really
bullish on a bunch of things but first
one thing that we get we speak a lot
about is focus and this is a little
fluffy so we don't spend too much
I'm on it but when you get to a certain
point you have the ability to do a lot
of different things so I have invested
enough ton of [ __ ] so but now I'm like
ah [ __ ] I can't pay attention to that
real estate deal can't pay attention to
this I really need to focus on only this
thing and maybe one other thing what's
your criteria for saying no and saying
yes complete intuition every time and
when I say yes the things outside the
core Vayner X I always treat it as it
goes to zero but I know that I need it
because I need to get my entrepreneurial
nut off so what's that mean then that
means that I need to absolutely make
that fifty thousand dollar investment or
do that thing to make the whole machine
work aka the 25% of things I'm doing
that make no sense and stretch me to
thin are actually the thing that gives
me sanity and happiness which allows us
75% of the Vayner focus to actually run
at 150% so empathy mines is one of them
yes and so that's your 25% it's one of
them I mean look I you know I'm a funny
guy talk a lot I talk a lot about a lot
of things and I don't talk about some of
the best things about me like who I am
as a human in like the deep like what
Alex knows not what you guys know my
nonprofits I don't and my board work
there I don't talk about that I also
don't talk about my single biggest eggs
and I I co-founded and co-created resi
the restaurant app like literally me and
Ben Leventhal over dinner he came up
with the idea I
they were incubated at vaynermedia when
the company was in a bad moment I
personally put money in I spent a lot of
social capital getting Danny Meyer and
Steve Ross definitely deeply involved i
Ben and Mike Montero or absolutely the
drivers of that business but like I am
easily the birth father and the third
player in that story it's a hefty nine
figure exit to Amex and I have a funny
feeling that 93 percent the people have
just heard a story heard it for the
first time case was sold nine months ago
there is no confusion to why
I barely mentioned it I have just
tweeted about it this week and
everyone's like all Congrats
so I need those things to make me sane
they've also led to a ton of big wins
the resi win covers every potential loss
I have yeah that's what the Airbnb it's
sold to know everybody was an investor
though it's sold to MX good
it was extremely good hefty nine figures
no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
Wow so so you know I think that I have
to do a better job of like communicating
some of those things to but just week
has raised money for that we did we did
first from Boehner vayner/rse my fund
incubated it so you know you got a
double win then I got a double win I got
a triple win because I put personal
money in when it needed it so but the
reality is is that I think when I hear
you say that I have a lot of empathy for
you because I have a funny feeling we
cross over in a lot of ways I would tell
you that don't over look at it from a
black-and-white standpoint cuz to your
point I mean there's so many things you
know when you come from nothing like
when people email me and say Gary bad
news you know really sorry you know but
the investment you wrote into my
company's going to zero we're shutting
down the doors but don't worry I learned
a lot I get pissed I'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like $50,000 $100,000 is a
ton of money to me like it doesn't
matter how much I make any that I earn
that I bled for that I bled for that
[ __ ] so you know I think that um but I
also would say to you on the flip side
I'm sure what you're realizing is some
of those checks you wrote you're gonna
you when you wrote it you imagine how
much you were gonna help that thing to
success and now you may never talk to
that founder yeah and I think that
happened to me and the way I look at it
now hey I changed my behavior a little
bit B what do you mean was I stopped
investing as much and would invest where
I thought by accident I could help just
by maybe you know when you build a brand
to your name can help I have absolutely
invested when I believed in something
and believed in the person and knew that
my investment will help them raise more
money so I thought a lot about that but
yeah I mean I I think it I think all
those micro losses is
I'm gonna macro win I need it I'm an
artist I'm creative by Nature I need it
so you wanna talk about some interesting
things that we've been good over on
please on in the hustling on trends that
I think you'll enjoy rippin on please
okay so you guys Vayner had a real
estate conference yes how'd that go
financially financially it went well
where where it was vulnerable was he
said something stupid to get in trouble
no I didn't get to say anything stupid I
still believe in it I said that sorry I
don't mean stupid I mean I guess I know
what you meant
three things one right so to your point
on that one it was agent 2021 it was run
100% by Kim Garcia I always knew that
Kim might not stay long-term and so
there was the the vulnerability was
unlike anything outside you at
vaynermedia there was no backup to Kim
going on in her career which is why we
didn't do it this year as far as the
backlash I stay I'll triple down on it
right now which I agree with you a
unning amount of people overextend
themselves on their first house purchase
just to say they bought a home everybody
almost maximizes their down payment
which eliminates cash flow almost
everybody buys a home that's too big for
them and has an extra bedroom or living
room that they never use and I think for
people that are entrepreneurial and are
trying to grow happiness and business
capabilities that they need to rethink
their buying home strategy and lean into
more renting so that they have the
liquid to go on the offense so they can
then buy a home at 39 or 57 or never so
I believe in that and then so the
industry took that as you know Gary says
never buy home and I love that my
sister's a real estate agent I thought I
still I believe in a triple and when I
tell you I give no [ __ ] to the backlash
of people that have financial vested
interest in people buying homes for
themselves not having empathy for the
person that buys the home then go [ __ ]
themselves
so this next conference of yours sounds
like it's gonna go great yeah I mean the
cop of the conference is easy right like
the conference like is is it was a good
business for you guys it was an OK
business we made we made six figures on
both executions
to sponsorships and ticket sales I love
the events business yes let's talk about
it so I did a big case studies I studied
the top five companies you know there's
a company called informa you know
informal I do
I love informa it's a fifteen billion
dollar market cap their mother
margins are significantly larger than a
lot of these huge tech companies like
Atlassian things like that who I
compared them to I mean they could do
three or four billion dollars a year in
tradeshow revenue with like a 40% net
income margin fad and specifically I
think there's been and and there's some
lacking in the construction field and a
few other industries but I love the
trade show of industry I love it I think
I think there's a huge opportunity there
what we and what were you saying about
why you love them because they're highly
profitable and humans will continue to
interact then everyone's attention is
unscalable tech not humanity and
non-scalable [ __ ] like that and at scale
you can you can really do damage yeah
but a lot of people don't realize it
because it seems how unsexy is not
interested that's I mean bro every
single one of my friends made fun of me
for starting vaynermedia it's a client
service business they didn't really they
need an i to your point back to like why
I would never judge somebody that wants
to do a hundo in 2025 you know how you
navigate by being a runner that gives me
a lot of insight actually gives with me
a lot of inside of me I never compete
with myself I don't run or whatever
though I was pumped I did break my
jumping my jump rope record this
Saturday Sunday with Mike on how many I
can do in 12 minutes but nonetheless I
would tell you that non-sexy businesses
right now that have true business
fundamentals are by far the most
interesting that what else is more
interesting than sports cards I'm sorry
to bring it up again
all my friends are like this is stupid
it's all gonna go Tech I'm like cool I
really don't think so like physical
things are not going away from your
society so then what were the
opportunities through exchange
marketplaces yeah somebody's gonna build
a true you know there's something called
calm sea there's a company running
around right now raising capital that's
a true merkel exchange type thing where
you never take any of the cards you
short you you you buy futures yes I also
think sports like music is a fundamental
pill
like I love history the Romans biggest
events where people [ __ ] fighting you
chat like boxing and fighting a lion and
whatever the [ __ ] but like this is never
going away and I think that if you look
at culture look at look at all of us
right now there's a lot of young
professionals in this room I'm gonna
call myself young the way we're dressed
like every person here doing the same
thing we're doing right now in 1974
looks totally different the casual
nature the culture nature and I think
art is not this generations favorite
thing though there's cool art and
there's a lot of fun things than I'm
actually in an art business I like a lot
called iconic but either the posters
uh-huh I'm a very big fan that because
of sneaker culture and because of urban
culture that I think that sports cards
are about to become the next art and so
like a lot of what I'm buying
whether it's Colin Kaepernick which is
cultural not what he can do on the field
because he's probably not gonna be on
the field again or or basketball soccer
wrestling cards like I think they're the
next art with another place another way
you detect that market um shovels and
picks right cuz I'm just great you know
back to the way you ask that question
the more thoughtful business the one
that I've less interest in but where the
bigger economics are is the
infrastructure around it let's just
parlay our two conversations the core
event is called the national it's the
biggest sports card show how big is it
I don't know you know who owns it I do
not but I can tell you since I've been
to the last two it's it's great and it's
part of the hobbies tradition but
there's clearly opportunity and I don't
know on the comp of comic-con if the
people that originally owned it
then just became what it became today I
would love that for the family that's
been in it on the national but either
them or a competitor coming in clearly
has an opportunity to create an events
business that is going to matter because
you can see the enter like regional
shows are so mom if I mean it's exactly
what you think they look like but
there's a place for it to go pop culture
there's grading companies the whole
industry is built on yes I was you know
that PSA is a publicly traded company
that I think the stock has done well
recently there's starting the IP company
there's
the next brand upper neck tops FLIR yes
a PSA is the grading company there's
three good grading there's three leaders
in grading SGC pSATS
what's the Moody's for stocks I don't
know what's the Moody's Moody's maybe
they give you like the a triple-a rating
all right the ratings coming yeah this
is a this is a little bit more flawed
it's human it's like appraisal on how
good the car there's a lot of anxiety of
this business because there's people
that try to trim cards or alter cards
authenticity like it's humans great I
like that there's being an IP company
right now panini and tops own all the
rights but you could start a new company
or buy one of the old brands and then
get the rights from the NBA or them or
the MLB so there's the IP renting
company kind of like ESPN and and Fox
get the rights for the league's that's
how sports cards work there's the
expansion I've been thinking a lot about
creating hip hop cards like you know
what would happen if you went into a new
arena and created cards Pokemon and
Magic the Gathering haven't even started
the process of they're already
ridiculously expensive but that age
group is younger that was the 90s
generation cards whereas the 80s with
sports
so there's non sports cards there's
there's a lot of variables so I'm gonna
have our analyst and our team going
I love it write that up please and I'll
give a ton exposure from I've heard from
a lot of people the quality of your guys
work is really good so if you're gonna
go really deep and do it I know it on
surface level intuition and like little
parts but like some of the data like I
don't know if there's been a single
better thing to invest in in the last
year than sports cards including crypto
anything good that has happened in
crypto cannabis stock like we're talking
about 20 30 40 X returned in six and
nine months liquid like one thing that
you know that sucks about angel
investing is you're locked yeah for
eight years 10 years right I mean you
bought a you know I bought 53 of them I
wish about 500 of them you buy
fifty-three LeBrons last spring I'm
talking eight months ago for a thousand
they're [ __ ] 4,500 right now and and
there's dumb
and the reason is that young people
buying it or older everybody it's just
happening I'll tell you who's buying my
generation that now has wealth that's
going back to their childhood nostalgia
always works there eight year olds so
the kids of the core group gamblers the
amount of gambling culture and sports is
heavy daily fantasy actual betting prop
betting you've seen all that explosion
well guess what like if you know sports
another way to gamble is to put it into
players you believe in and then sneaker
flipper kids the enormity of that
industry that has been massively
disrupted by stock X and IPOs
you can't go to the sneaker store
anymore and hire 80 of your high school
friends to stand in line get the easies
bring them back give them 10 bucks each
and then go make real money that's yeah
that's wild I've enjoyed watching that
thing
what's another industry that has been
exciting you one one that I that I mean
TC brands that are not vc-backed slow
and steady
I'm gonna build a thirty nine million
dollar t-shirt business dumb business
honey business but I'm not gonna do it
like Casper voice is correct I didn't
see yet the CEO had to step down I don't
know if it's a fire step down okay how
much did they how much did they raise
you know like forty or fifty million
dollars so did this they raise fifty
million dollars or something the revenue
was only forty nine and they're losing
two million dollars a month I've got a
friend that has a business that sells
dog ramps that does three million a
month in revenue with nothing I mean
it's crazy how this is the whole theme
in this whole conversation it's why I
pressed early on the more we don't
become like it the more likely we're
gonna be super alright hot dog you is
the best version of you yeah and I think
that that is what we're on the dawn of I
think a lot of what I'm talking about
do you know what do you understand the
utter carnage on a neck if this
coronavirus thing continues its momentum
let let there be no confusion I don't
know when we're hearing this I assume
this week next week so it's not gonna be
too far but like as of this morning
the more pain which people isn't spanner
being shut or Milan are being shut down
I'm again I'm headline reading so I'm
talking out of
my ass and not out of my ass I just had
a breakfast I look up all red CNBC
coronavirus I had a friend hit me up
over the weekend saying like hey this in
America this is a little bit weirder
than you think this is who my uncle is
I'm like that's weird wait wait what's
that mean
just said hey this is more serious in
America than you think and you'll be
finding out in next hundred days because
I'm not a big conspiracy theorist so
putting that out there I hope I've
scared nobody but like I'm just sharing
like where I'm going is whether it's
[ __ ] coronavirus or the inevitable
economic downturn nobody's building real
businesses anymore you know that all of
Silicon Valley New York to your point
nobody's building actual businesses yeah
I think it's crazy that these people
raise money for some of these DC brands
it's crazy
it's because they can there's so much
money in the system yeah there's too
much money less system and they don't
realize they'll get way richer by not
doing that they just they they like the
perception of success versus actual
success because it's actually incredibly
cheap to do this the perception it also
brother I'll tell you this though it's
time we talk about entrepreneurship and
talent you and I got lucky in the
[ __ ] DNA game it is not so easy like
to it I understand what you're saying
and I say it too let's flip it around
it's actually super hard to build a
sustainable business where you're not
being [ __ ] trust funded all these
startups are trust funds what I always
tell people I'm like intellectually it's
not that hard
emotionally it's it's super challenging
and a life and they can't just balance
you couldn't lose
nothing's complicated intimate
intellectually this is all emotion but
people don't have the stomach for losing
and judgement yeah I mean starting these
DC brands like I know a bunch of people
doing I'm like this is really not that
hard
what's more fun for 99 percent of the
people listening and the world right now
hey go raise money and look like you're
killing it and have CEO in your
Instagram title and have money to go
spend because you're paying yourself
enough and all this stuff or eat dog
[ __ ] for four and a half years to build
a foundation to maybe get to that a same
exact place but you're on stable ground
and then you can start the process at
maybe in eight years it can look good
the end who the [ __ ] is gonna pick eight
years over eight minutes
one percent which is why that one
percents about to win big is there
anything else you like I'm fascinated by
the whole psychedelic thing oh that's so
obvious to me like the whole Aubrey and
Ferriss and all that circles yeah huge
on it men's makeup men's makeup one
men's makeup I know we're wrapping I
know everyone's trying to get us to wrap
up we're having too much fun I got a
real hot take not short term sports
cards short term how about psychedelic
so what I can tell is that this
psychedelics are only repressed as a
stigma no I mean I don't even don't have
a cigarette
like I'm super weird right yeah I drink
wine um but I've been drunk like five
times I'm completely sober and I love
that but I still love that thing
yeah me too cuz I don't have feelings
and opinions when it comes to business
you do I probably wouldn't because my
mom Nancy Reagan me out too much it's a
framework for me but I'll say this I'll
never say never like I'm willing to do
whatever the [ __ ] I need to do at any
point it's just not in my framework on
the flip side on I'm also way too
grateful and thankful of my mental
happiness and I would be lying if I
didn't tell you that I'd be scared to
alter something or you know a lot of
people do it because it finds a
dimension that works for them I'm like
my current state is working for me
I don't want to open up something be
like oh [ __ ] and like you know yeah like
like don't fix it yet to you but if I
wasn't mentally happy I'm open for
everything everything's in play have you
heard of MDMA therapy no I think it's a
it's awesome Tucker Tucker Max is told
he's one of our investors yep he's
because I go to therapy and I used to
take antidepressants he was like dude do
this I've been on this medication for
years and I did this thing I feel way
better anything that helps people get
off medication is something intuitively
in my gut not I'm not a doctor I don't
know like I'm sure there's plenty of
medicines that matter but I'm always
pumped knowing enough about the business
of Pharma in America I'm always pumped
if people can find a different way but
back to psychedelics uh and like and
sexual experimentation like what you're
seeing right now is a mature practical
version of what you saw in the 60s I
think it's a game of stigma what's an
example of well I think you know when I
think about my friends in Silicon Valley
who talked about you know psychedelics
something
nature inevitably in that same dinner it
gets into alternative sexual
relationships and like an open like open
marriage is in a more progressive way
than open marriages or like I would know
I don't think I could never do that it's
not for me either like what but I don't
like imposing my like what I think makes
me successful in these talks is I never
impose my will or opinion on what will
happen all my friends that are like [ __ ]
how did I got tick-tock wrong it's like
and whether tick tock disappears
tomorrow or not there's incredible money
being made in the tick-tock
infrastructure and that's what we're
talking about business in this narrow
way and I'm they're like why are you
always right I'm like because I don't
impose my opinion you're because I'm
talking to these inner circle friends
I'm like you said it was stupid for you
you said that because you're insecure
you have 800 thousand followers on
Instagram and you don't want to start
over you're doing what Tila Tequila and
Dane Cook did with MySpace
you're doing what all my homies and
Twitter did about Instagram you now are
doing that to Instagram you're so set in
your thing and you've got clout you
don't want the world to reset I only
want the world to reset because I don't
actually value my clout I value
learnings and impact it's a huge deal so
help psychedelics real quick to finish
yourself and then jump in with your for
your helps psychedelics stigma is gonna
go away which is then gonna make people
feel comfortable to do it and I have a
very deep intuitive feeling that is the
medicine or whatever the [ __ ] you want
to call it that's gonna help a fuckload
of people who have not been able to find
their alternative in advil or in therapy
or in much harder core medicine and that
excites the [ __ ] out of me I want way
more happiness in the world
go ahead is there anything else exciting
you DTC sports cards live like it's
funny we've talked about a live events
DTC in sports cards practical dtc cuz
it's there but it can't take funding 10
years not 10 minutes sports cards I'm
obsessed live events up obsess for the
DDC is there any particular products
your fascinator everything's category
every single thing that's sold in a
store is vulnerable to do you see what I
like to do is just look at Procter &
Gamble everything they sell you just
know dart at it every editor than that
and I like what you did cuz Proctor is a
leader but like take it all
anything that's sold in a store Target
just walk around
anything yeah and that then tells every
entrepreneur because I know a lot are
listening right now sell what you love
like if you love blueberry jam [ __ ]
make that brand back to you saying it's
easy it has never been easier to be like
I love peanut butter and jelly for real
for real I love it it's never been
easier on earth and I mean the Delta is
like a billion to zero on starting a
peanut butter and jelly brand if you
take a ten year window if you take a ten
year window
let me tell you real life instead of
this Vichy [ __ ] and I know we're late
but [ __ ] I'm pumped right now if you
sell dumb [ __ ] in your house
I don't money very good you have stuff
in your house you're like most Americans
have stuff even like people that aren't
making a lot of money have [ __ ] stuff
at least a thousand dollars of crap yes
and if you don't I'll teach you and I
keep teaching people I'll teach you how
to take 30 bucks and turn into a
thousand I [ __ ] did in trash talk
episode three it was called twenty
dollars of Olympic pins for over a
thousand real-life real talk do you have
the humility to go garage saleing that's
the question you have humility to go to
dollar store and walk out and while
everybody is that bad Whole Foods and
sees you walking out with bags from a
dollar store people are like judgment
you have the humility when you don't
have a car to go pick up something on
Craigslist and take the [ __ ] bus and
sit with a lamp on your lap like why
wouldn't you want to do that that's
that's fun because it's easier for
people mentally to complain and blame
than to take on accountability
accountable as [ __ ] tell them I wanted
this afternoon Alex so nonetheless if
you can get twenty thousand bucks by
eating [ __ ] for a year and grinding then
you can then take that twenty thousand
dollars to develop early stage peanut
butter and jelly brand early stage
Instagram and tick tock ads an early
stage early stage early stage
aka ten years but in ten years if you're
32 could you imagine being able to quit
your job at 42 that you [ __ ] hate and
are dying inside and do a business
around your singular thing your singular
thing I'm talking everybody needs to
hear this this is crush of 2008 it I was
right it's real like people are still
not doing it [ __ ] where you see the
opportunity because you read the hustle
and trends and you like [ __ ] there's not
that's great and by the way you might be
like me by the way me I'm a businessman
I can get fired up about anything
yeah we just heard out right but if
you're [ __ ] hardcore toothpastes like
you like like it you like buy different
brands you're intrigued by it it's
vulnerable if you're like hardcore
skiing like you like n video work like
go become the person that [ __ ] does
content on ski mountains it's real it's
[ __ ] real but you have to think of it
in ten years because anybody who thinks
it's real thinks you have to raise money
everybody thinks you have to raise money
now it's [ __ ] broke it's never been
cheaper maybe if you live in San
Francisco but I was some people I go to
[ __ ] San Francisco to New Mexico what
a Missouri that's right no for real
whenever I said when BuzzFeed and box
were doing their thing I was tweeting I
was like move your offices to st. Louis
you'll be profitable anyway bro I really
we have the hustle and trends and all
that but we also have this cool podcast
that where I was talking to your guy
we're gonna be close and beating you in
the numbers that's my goal be happy no
I'm not on a hard time on some real [ __ ]
you know to the group Kobe Bryant was
the most competitive iconic figure in
our culture and when he tweeted a
congratu is last tweet and couldn't be
more simple similar and that's right and
that's what that's who I am nothing
makes me happier than when entrepreneurs
on merit out work out succeed me cuz
that's the game either you love the game
where you don't so these last five
minutes when we were just riffing on
interesting opportunities what we do is
we just research all of them and we just
riff on them and we have experts coming
sometimes it's all my first million if
you're wondering if you're in San
Francisco and ever want to come on it
like I said well a similar reason is now
come and do it I'm happy to do it
thank you for having me
you